UNION ADDRESS LAST NIGHT,
THE VISUALS BECAME A PUBLIC
RELATIONS NIGHTMARE PER
PETULANT GRUMPY DEMOCRATS.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS
SIGNALED THEY DIDN'T LIKE.
>> WE PROUDLY STAND FOR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THE MOTTO IS IN GOD WE
TRUST.
[APPLAUSE]
WE ENACTED THE BIGGEST TAX
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
GIVING OUR VETERANS CHOICE
IN THEIR HEALTHCARE
DECISIONS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: LET'S BRING IN
REPUBLICAN POLSTER PUBLIC
OPINION GURU FRANK LUNTZ.
HE JOINS US FROM WEST
VIRGINIA.
ALL RIGHT, FRANK.
LAUGHING WHEN THINGS LIKE IN
GOD WE TRUST AND THEN THEY
PAN THE CROWD AT THE STATE
OF THE UNION, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE ALL SITTING ON THEIR
HANDS.
OVER THE EDGE?
>> WELL, THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
HEAR ANY SUCCESS.
ANY TIME DONALD TRUMP
POINTED TO A SPECIFIC
STATISTIC A FACT ABOUT
THINGS HAD CHANGED THE LAST
12 MONTHS YOU SAW NO
REACTION FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
SECOND, ANY TIME HE
SUGGESTED THAT HE WAS GOING
TO REACH ACROSS THE AISLE
AND FIND SOME SORT OF
BIPARTISAN, THEY WANTED NO
PART OF IT.
THIRD IT GOES BACK TO THE
PROMISES HE MADE AND THE
FACT THAT HE IS ATTEMPTING
TO KEEP THEM AND I THINK
IT'S A TRAGEDY, QUITE
FRANKLY, THAT THE DEMOCRATS
DON'T REALIZE THAT WITH
DONALD TRUMP'S SUCCESS,
AMERICA SUCCEEDS.
LAURA, A LOT OF PEOPLE
CRITICIZED THE REPUBLICANS
UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY
WANTED HIM TO FAIL AND, YET,
THE COUNTRY, THAT TOO MANY
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS WANT
TRUMP TO FAIL SO THEY CAN
TAKE OVER THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM.
>> Laura: WHAT'S AMAZING ON
THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE DONALD
TRUMP 800,000 TO 1.8 MILLION
GETTING AMNESTY.
I'M REALLY TO COMPROMISE,
LET'S GET THIS DONE
TOGETHER.
IT'S LIKE CRICKETS, TUMBLE
WEEDS BLOWING THROUGH THE
SECTION.
>> I'M IN WEST VIRGINIA
RIGHT NOW.
THE GENTLEMEN STANDING
BEHIND ME.
THEY ARE THE REASON WHY
DONALD TRUMP MAINTAINS HIS
POPULARITY AND WHY HE DID SO
WELL LAST NIGHT.
THEY FEEL LISTENED TO.
THEY FEEL HEARD.
A LOT OF AMERICANS FELT LEFT
OUT UNTIL ELECTION DAY 2016.
ON IMMIGRATION, THE PUBLIC
HAS TO UNDERSTAND THAT IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THE
DEMOCRATS THEMSELVES ARE
READY TO COMPROMISE.
AND IF YOU DON'T GET THIS
LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDES
BORDER SECURITY AS WELL AS A
SOLUTION FOR DACA, IF IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN, IT WON'T BE
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: FRANK, I THOUGHT
YOU NEEDED BODY GUARDS FOR A
SECONDS.
I WANT THOSE GUYS TO TRAVEL
WITH ME.
THEY LOOK PRETTY STRONG.
I LOVE IT.
>> I ASKED THEM THE QUESTION
ARE ANY OF THESE GUYS
PACKING?
THIS GUY RIGHT HERE, HE IS
GOOD.
OKAY.
WE WILL LEAVE IT AT THERE.